this morning I want to ask you the
question are you really are you really
ready for them that is something that
people don't want to talk about and last
my witness there is not one day that
goes by that I don't think about death
not a day I think about death every day
and in fact I want you as the Prophet
Mohammed some Lala solemn said for us to
always constantly think about that
reminder that reminder of death you may
ask the question why let's first deal
with facts every two seconds
think about it nine babies born in this
earth and three people died in one year
on average 50 million people will die
I look around that this audience is
relatively young how many of you are 20
years or older raise your hand raise
Emma was your hand raised
I don't know you know whether he reached
20 is you might be surprised to learn
that from your birth 20 years ago
twenty-one years ago if 20 from the time
that you were born over 1 billion people
have died that means that every day you
live
you're that closer to the grave and the
thing that's in coming upon us to
understand is that we have no guarantees
the question is are you prepared for
death and I'm going to give you a test
this morning to see if you really
prepared